mesdames et messieurs peuple d internet
bonsoir l'heure est grave aujourd'hui
plus de 4 milliards 978 millions de
propriétaires de chats se font matraquer
par rue 89 points 98 % de ses
propriétaires laissent la majorité de la
place de leurs lits aux chats et 126 %
des lecteurs du livre dont je vous
parlais ont repris en trombe
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
treizième opus de ce calendrier de
l'avent aujourd'hui je vous parle comme
idée de cadeau du jour avec qui m'a
beaucoup fait rire parce que j'ai un
chat moi-même qui s'appelle thomas l'eau
que vous avez déjà peut-être déjà vu sur
mon état g
et si vous l'avez pas vu c'est que vous
êtes peut-être pas abonnés à mon
instinct g vous avez le lien dans la
description et voilà c'est fait bien oui
car comme ça vient d'être marqué juste
ici et les livres qui m'a fait rien
c'est pourquoi les chardons il conquérir
le monde
des témoignages accablants enfin la
vérité bon on va pas se mentir j'ai
souvent du mal avec les livres
d'humour où à chaque page est une vanne
un peu mise en page etc
ça marche pas trop sur moi j'arrive pas
lire en fête et celui ci bizarrement il
se lit très bien mais je crois aussi
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de compétition
il ya des photos et vous avez compris le
parti pris de ce livre vous attendiez à
trouver des chats mignons dans ses
livres et bien non et l'amant loisirs
est prêt ana petits morceaux choisis
le top 10 oui on est sur internet même
dans les livres maintenant le top 10 de
manière dont un chat peut vous tuer donc
je vous lis les gros titres vous lis pas
après le petit texte rigole en dessous
petit 1 ils se posent sur votre tête
pour vous tuer dans votre sommeil petit
2 il vous griffe souvent petit soit il
vous oblige à le suivre
petit 4 il fait tomber des objets petit
sac il vous fera choper une maladie
dégueulasse petit 6 l'utilisent la force
jour après jour grâce à son cerveau
surpuissant le ch est capable de vous
irradiés il utilise la force la force la
vraie force
[Musique]
tintin tintin 20 ans le pouce en l'air
du mettra petit set il se met dans vos
jambes de 18 il vous fait de gros câlins
pour vous étouffez petit 9 il vous pique
votre nourriture petit 10 il vous fait
tourner en bourrique
mais d'autres escales s'utiliser par
tous les élèves de collèges consiste à
faire tourner un humain en rond pour lui
faire péter une durite répétés sur toute
une vie comme peut le faire un chat
cette méthode d'assas mer est très
efficace et surtout ne laisse aucune
trace vols sont partout via des photos
commentées ya les analyses scientifiques
et biologiques du spécimen du chat au
tout début il ya son emploi du temps
aussi qui est très chargé on peut voir
qu à 13h28 le chat conspirent avec les
chaînes les autres chats du quartier 4
histoires 56 il ya un quart d'heure de
folie obligatoire se tait mieux
découvrir donc à 19h07 dormir un peu
parce que c'était épuisant mais à 19h34
surveiller le déroulé du roppa y
participer activement
20h56 faire beaucoup de bruit pendant le
film pendant que pour que l'humain ne
puisse pas le suivre 22h24 déposer une
souris sur l'oreiller afin qu'il ne
tombe pas tout de suite d'un 3h02
prendre toute la place dans le lit pour
qu'ils n'osent pas bougé etc etc
des témoignages je vous en lire un parce
que je crois que vous avez coup mieux
comprendre de quoi on parle
je sais pas si vous êtes prêts pour ça
anthony 46 ans célibataire c'était dans
le gouffre mons a mené en bateau il
faisait de moi ce qu'il voulait je
craque à chaque fois mais j'étais un
battant mais dès que je rentrais chez
moi c'était fini il avait trop de
pouvoir sur moi en vrai je l'invitais
plus personne à la maison sinon je
serais passer pour une victime
observez la nuit pendant mon sommeil
parfois encore j'ai l'impression qu'il
va surgir la dario et ce qui m'a fait le
plus marrer mais je terminerais je pense
à vidéo là dessus c'est que à plusieurs
chapitres sont repris des études
scientifiques réel qu'on était visant le
comportement animalier sur les chiens
sur les êtres humains et sur les chats
et ils s'en servent pour les retourner
avec humour pour prouver
scientifiquement que les chats veulent
notre peau et ça s'est extrêmement bien
fait en termes de rhétorique et
d'analysé créativité et
l'avenir il y en a trois études
scientifiques dedans j'ai trouvé ça très
drôle je voulais donc vous en parler
j'ai bien aimé ce livre je vous mets le
lien dans la description ça peut être un
bon cadeau de noël ce livre comme ça des
objets présentés autre chose des places
pour aller voir fabian licka a levé un
vieil album de septembre 2018 n'y aura
pas de chat mais par conduira peut-être
toi moi comme d'habitude vous pouvez
laisser les cassettes vidéo s'est pas
encore fait ou vous abonnez si c'est pas
fait non plus je vous dis demain parce
que c'est le principe d'un calendrier de
l'avent
on va se retrouver tous les jours
jusqu'au 24 décembre et passer une bonne
journée
parce qu'il était tôt alors à demain
matin 6h ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on